how'd you guys meet each other
you're currently married yes to each
other yeah yeah to each other
all right cool how'd you guys meet I was
watching his YouTube stuff like 2018 I
think like because it was the Swedish
election around that time and I was
interested in politics and then
um I think he said in one of his videos
that he had an Instagram and that he
needed people to stop dming him that
wasn't Cutie Pie's and then I messaged
him and said am I a cutie pie and the
Europe pie in like two minutes
and then that that's when I was in New
Zealand
and I guess you wanted to escape America
or like La for a little bit and um where
were you mentally there look because
we've talked to this timeline where it's
2018. was it 1819 where is the low point
or is that that was way early low Point
carpet cleaning that was like two
thousand uh 2010. okay 2018 was probably
your Peak
what do you like now is my Peak what do
you mean
nobody ever admits being past their
Prime just just well I mean my prime
minister okay it was around it was
probably around the time where you were
getting a lot of lefties through your
community and you were really like
thinking about that they would go too
far maybe that was I think that was
still when Hassan and wash were both in
my community exactly so I would say if
it feels like there was not really like
much issues when it comes to like to
your stuff or like your work stuff back
then oh suddenly we didn't talk about is
it like um there were no Politics on
Twitch I exclusively inhabited that
place for like two years because nobody
else did it because it was a really
toxic environment for politics so for a
couple of years as it grew like the I
kind of grew the whole Space because it
wasn't nobody was doing it yet what did
that look like you're having
like political debates political
discourse yeah mainly like going into
YouTube people to try to argue with them
or just doing Politics on stream like
reading stories researching stuff
talking about stuff but there's not like
other people on Twitch to debate about
politics because there was no politics
it was yeah was there a debate in the
space of Communism socialism social
Democrats kind of like this are you
trying to outline your own position
during that time I think it was mainly
me fighting against conservatives
because it was like Trump stuff and then
it was coming off the back of like there
was this movie called gamergate and
there was all this anti-sjw stuff on the
internet and I was like the sjw like the
progressive that was fighting on the
Progressive side of things so I think
that's what I was known for but I was
fighting with people off of twitch
because on Twitch there weren't very
many political discussions happening so
you were holding the sjw flag yeah uh to
what to what degree do you still hold it
like what's the best what's the Steel
Man case for sjw I mean like I'm still
very much that sjw from 2018 2019 but
the positions have moved so much farther
left that I don't know some people may
not call me that anymore I'm not sure it
depends on who I'm talking to because
basically what is a social justice worry
like being sensitive to the experience
of others yeah being sensitive and
empathetic towards the experience of
others and then trying to build a better
world that like suits as many different
types of people as possible while being
like aware of like their names